[Music]  taylor swift's lays on Saturday Night  Live the singer performed two songs off  her smash hit new album reputation first  bringing dance moves during ready for it  [Music]  then grabbing her guitar for an intimate  performance of call it what you want and  keeping with the somatic nature of her  album that's a sparkling snake twisting  around Taylor's mic and there was also  one slithering up her sweatshirt  reputation is set to become Taylor's  fourth album to sell more than 1 million  copies in just a week many of the tracks  seemingly delve into Taylor's turbulent  past months and her new love with  British actor Johanna wit et's taken a  deep dive into the lyrics you can check  out our analysis at e t-- online.com  where you can also get a full recap of  SNL stellar episode with Taylor and  Tiffany Haddish  [Music]